el presidente estadounidense Joe biden
pronunciara su tercer discurso del
estado de la unión en medio de
divisiones en el legislativo y en un
tenso panorama internacional es
justamente en el congreso en donde Joe
biden se encuentra más debilitado los
republicanos lograron una mayoría en la
cámara de representantes tras una tensa
pugna electoral en los comicios de medio
término los demócratas lograron mantener
el control del senado a pesar de que
parecía una derrota anunciada para el
partido del presidente
unos resultados que le siguen cobrando
factura para pasar buena parte de sus
proyectos lo que esto creará es un
verdadero desafío para las cosas que se
avecinan como Elevar el techo de la
deuda aprobar un presupuesto las cosas
imprescindibles para el gobierno
requieren la coordinación republicana un
escenario un poco más favorable se vive
en el plano económico biden podrá
celebrar algunas victorias en enero se
crearon 517,000 empleos nuevos y la tasa
de desempleo cayó del 3,5% al 3
la inflación cerró en 2022 en el 6,5%
debajo del 9% de mitad de año unas
cifras que Siguen sin acercarse al
deseado 2%, impidiendo el descenso de
los precios la agenda internacional
sigue siendo un factor importante el
discurso llega después del anuncio de un
nuevo paquete de ayudas a Ucrania y en
medio de la escalada de tensiones con
china luego de que las fuerzas de
Estados Unidos derribaran un globo de
dicho país que supuestamente era
utilizado para espionaje la violencia
policial también marcará la locución la
madre y el padrastro de Tyler Nichols un
joven afroamericano asesinado por las
fuerzas de seguridad del país están
invitados al evento
es poco probable que el presidente haga
mención a la polémica en torno a los
documentos clasificados hallados en su
oficina tema que presumiblemente se ha
utilizado en su contra en la réplica
republicana que este año estará a cargo
de la gobernadora de Arkansas